remember to take only certified neural
enhancement supplements
some parts of the brain
it is good to see you be seems pretty uh
secluded here it is appropriate for such
a secret meeting
friend you mentioned here oda
he should be here any moment now willing
finally to give me the speck on him
hanukkah arasaka's from the carrier at
anchor in the bay
saburo's daughter yes and if he believes
you
we'll next meet with her
sure you can trust him yes
convincing very i have nothing to lose
is that better worse because i got
plenty to lose
a good sign he is usually camouflaged
[Music]
can speak for myself you know so speak
i have been told you know things
was there saw what happened you're a
nobody strangle the old guy
silence not one word
you will bring death to your door
but it is the truth
my one concern is to keep her safe
in this city forgotten by the gods is
she in danger
now no yet during the parade to honor
arasaka
most certainly i bring you this witness
to his
murder and you dare to worry about the
silly parade
fool correct unlike you
i have not yet failed to keep my oath
but you can't ignore the truth
you will regret those words the only
thing i regret
is that i came here to meet you
there is a price on your head i do you a
favor now
by not cutting it off and taking it
straight to your inaudible summer
what would you do now were you in my
place
i do no favors i would deliver you a
head to your inosama
consider yourself lucky that i
am not you you cannot ignore this
good [ __ ] riddance one arasaka whack
job is already
plenty
well can't say we didn't try
we tried yes and obtained
something useful how do you figure that
what oda said they returned to tokyo
after the parade do you not see
the parade it is our chance
perhaps if somehow
we can get to hanakusama we must do a
proper reconnaissance
first we'll need a precise map of japan
town
hold on it is your turn to go down
friends do you know a fixer who could
help
no just a fixer dame kaku akata
runs a pachinko parlor on jig jig street
we must pay this woman opposite
will you join me sure why not
gg street what is this name
just a night city name
bewear you mock me too often
you alright guro yes
i'm just asking is everything with you
have to have an ulterior motive
i am wrong
i am
any idea what's going on at our soccer
is
um
yes
how i miss the sound
rogue my sweet this has got to be a
misunderstanding
i have no idea who jumped your team but
the claws
no never my boys know their place
i i'm sorry got to go i have
guests
v so nice to see you
and your charming friend is
happen to be working together that's all
a true gentleman oh
shame only that he's being hunted by all
our osaka's tin soldiers
and uv bring him to my door
give me one reason why i shouldn't
notify the proper
authorities right away
would have already made the call if you
intended to
simple you're curious to see what we got
so tell me and mark well i still have my
phone at hand
need intel on the parade that's
scheduled to come through japan town
so it's arasaka again
what i fail to understand is why come to
me
did mr deshawn not come to the phone
our socket tiger claws kind of like the
family dog screwing the cat huh can't
possibly be fond of the people who
killed your grandkid
that was very long ago time's the best
healer
wound like that though a wound like that
no
everything's on the sharks how much does
this cost
my pockets are empty clearly
my gift to you it's free
what is free often proves most costly
gonna take them or not
whole district is dashi platforms the
main attraction
they'll fly this way high above street
level
along the parade route balconies
footbridges and vantage points affording
good view
hanako arasaka a guest of honor will
deliver her speech from the largest
float
she'll do this exactly here
at the end the float that's it
it's all i have it must be enough
then go be on your way thanks mokako
we appreciate this
systems
yes as well until next time
foreign